yeah hey friend no ghosts oh god why did
I do that
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who continues moving on
and we have arrived at hide so this one
I actually remember not just thinking
was okay actively enjoying now re
watching it I don't think I liked it as
much this time as I did at the time that
it aired I think part of the thing was
at the time that it aired episodes
hadn't been much better than fine in a
bit so it felt like a breath of fresh
air going through straight through
series seven it's not quite as good as I
remember it being but I will stand by
this one I think it is underrated I
don't think it's given the credit it
deserves
so Hyde is the episode that deals with
the doctor and Clara arriving at a house
they are basically coming in on a
paranormal investigation you have a guy
with all this equipment trying to detect
the spirit that supposedly haunts this
place and you have the woman with him
who is empathic who's played by the same
actors who play Verity Lambert in an
adventure in space and time which I
hadn't realized before so that was cool
so first of all I love the setting I I
do I'd like these kinds of old-style big
houses are just good for ghost stories
they just are and I also enjoy that they
picked a time period where all of this
sort of supernatural paranormal trying
to figure out if we have the technology
to really detect ghosts sort of stuff
was really starting to pick up steam I
really enjoyed that element of it and in
addition to that I actually think it
handles the sort of haunted house
aspects pretty well it's since been
trumped by the hunting of Villa d-daddy
which was series 12 at least
of that specific element that one does
it even better than this but this still
does it pretty well and I also like that
the woman is not psychic but empathic
and I do like that the distinction is
made she can't read minds she can't see
into the future she just detects
people's feelings better she's more open
to just picking up on that whether she
wants to or not and having known people
that while I wouldn't say were empathic
on any kind of whoa that's like a
supernatural level thing I've know more
than a few people who are very
empathetic and empathic people who have
the feelings and the vibes around them
really impact them for better or for
worse so I kind of like that that got
highlighted there also the the dynamic
between her and the guy who owns the
house that works very well they've got
terrific chemistry and I also enjoy the
solution that's come up with this in
some ways it feels a little bit kind of
pulled out of nowhere that and I mean
it's the classic oh it's a ghost oh no
wait it's oh wait it's not aliens this
time ah it is time travel though which
will be the other go to but I kind of
like that I kind of like this idea that
there's this echo of a person that seems
like it never moves but is moving just
incredibly slowly across time and that
the TARDIS allows the doctor to just
realize that and to demonstrate it in a
way nobody else could so it also is one
of those situations where nobody else
could have figured this out except for
the doctor and not because of the sonic
screwdriver because using the base thing
that he does which is travelled through
time go back to the beginning of the
earth go to the end of the earth look at
that she's still there and she's running
hmm like that's a cool clever solution
and I do enjoy that Clara is fine in
this episode like I should I should be
clear she hasn't really been bad since
her introduction in the bells of st.
John she just is a bit she's
a little undercooked because I feel like
they have not bothered to properly
characterized this version of Clara we
get a way more impact on how other
people feel about her then from her
herself and that even gets added to here
with the sense that the TARDIS doesn't
really like her which once we find out
more about her kind of makes sense she's
a bit of an anomaly so the TARDIS is
gonna be thrown off about her but
overall we're getting more looks at how
other people feel about her how other
things are impacted by her and not
getting a great sense of her still that
said I still feel like this is one of
the better episodes that has both Matt
Smith and Jenna Coleman in it together I
think a lot of it just because it feels
like it's the one that has the nicest
distance from sort of the the mystery
that's that's going on and it doesn't
feel like it's leaning too hard on their
relationship either that might have been
something I didn't mention it in cold
war that might have been one of the
things that held it back it's one of
those episodes that feels like it was
really leaning on the doctor companion
relationship but the doctor convenien
relationship isn't as firmly established
as it should be for the degree to which
they're leaning on it at that point kind
of a little bit of the problem I have
with the beast below as well but here
because they're not leaning on that
dynamic as hard it's working for me just
fine and in addition to that there's
also the monster here's the thing part
of me says you don't need a monster for
this story it's not necessary because
what we find out about this woman as a
ghost is already intriguing itself we
have a ticking clock because you've got
limited time to be rescued there is an
inherent danger trying to go and rescue
her because the TARDIS isn't can't go
there at least not for more than a
couple seconds and that universe that
she's trapped in is collapsing so there
is enough built-in hazards that you
don't need a monster especially
considering that the monster is never
really an active threat until you get to
the very end and you realize it was
never trying to be an active threat it
was just there it just
happens to look and come across as super
dang scary but it's not and wow that
doesn't necessarily seamlessly integrate
with everything going on I still like it
so much that I'm totally good with it I
love that one of the most twisted Krrish
creations of the show that they went out
of their way to film in this weird
shuddery way and like get really badan
looks at and really it's just really
quick glimpses and even when you get a
decent look at it it's just twisted ah
just try to get back with us mate that's
awesome like I'm principal I like that
and I wish that kind of thing happened
more maybe I when I say that I don't
mean being inserted into the narrative
but I mean sort of the the playing
against the expectations because with
the universe as infinite as the one we
theoretically live in and the doctor
theoretically is saving on a regular
basis not everything that looks scary is
and I feel like the show has the
opportunity to play with that but
doesn't very much for the most part if
something looks like a monster it
behaves like a monster and I like here
that something very much looks like a
monster but no no it doesn't it is
especially fun to rewatch and realize
that this thing never actually threatens
them it never does anything to them like
at one point it's trying to reach them
but it never attacks them and to go back
and re-watch it and realize that and go
oh everyone was just spooked because it
looks freakish so if that doesn't happen
to like hit a particularly little oh
yeah kind of button for you the way does
for me I can see where that entire
element might be a bit superfluous and
doesn't add a lot because like I said it
doesn't especially seamlessly integrate
into the rest of the story because
you've already got a reason to have
flashes of things and effectively jump
scares from the ghost yourself and also
things like the sort of mirrored cracked
thing that shows up and things
like that that you don't need an extra
element just to grant you that
so they could have still had those kinds
of jump scares you know spook moments
even without it being there so it wasn't
like they would have lost that element
of a ghost story so I can't say that it
should it definitely needs to be there
however I still like it I like it enough
that I'm happy it's there even though I
can't I can explain why I like it if
somebody wants to make the argument it
has no business being there I can't
exactly defend it with anything concrete
other than it just works for me I dig it
so between that solid ghost story good
pacing nice atmosphere good moods good
supporting cast performance I like think
this is a small cast as well that as far
as human beings there's only four I like
that it's just a good tight little thing
and I think I said something similar
about cold war but cold war honestly
while I stand by the idea that it was
solid wasn't didn't leave as much of a
yeah there we go
things are getting back on track sort of
feeling that this does for me even
though I feel like cold war was a step
up certainly from rings of Akutan and
possibly even from bells of st. John
because I find more and more issue with
that thing
re watching it than when I first thought
but in any case I think this has a good
chance of I mean I've got a few more to
go but I think this is a good chance of
being the best episode of the latter
half of series 7 yeah I think it's
largely gonna depend on how well name of
the doctor holds up because I'm a
rewatch that in a while either but we'll
see but in and of itself if you have not
rewatched in a while I would recommend
you do so whatever your thoughts on Hyde
might be drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it until next
time this council is adjourned
thank you so much for tuning in if you
like what I do you can hit the like to
subscribe there's the Bell all those
wonderful things and also in a little
bit you will see some names scroll by
these are my patrons they help support
this show keep it going and help it
ideally grows bigger and better so
there's gonna be a link at the end of
the video for my patreon page and of
course is one down in the description
give it a click give it a look but you
also don't have to because at the end of
the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]